you know 9:00 a.m. Monday BART strike
fog cold hills and everything in between
so as Alastair and Michael both
mentioned this is kind of a part of a
big data probe program so I wanted to
begin to say well what is Big Data
and I'm sure kind of this room and other
rooms around campus have seen this
question answered many times but I want
to give you my spin on it and it's how
it relates to what I'm gonna talk about
it
all right so what is Big Data and to me
the sort of the simple and glib answer
is well it stated that doesn't fit into
your hard drive so of course it's big
but big means that it doesn't fit and
that really means that the size of Big
Data really been changing over the years
right so it might have been megabytes in
the 80s it's been gigabytes in the 90s I
remember buying my first sort of
gigabyte hard drive and thinking how
will I ever fill this up right
it was terabytes last decades and now
it's really kind of measuring in
petabytes right I can go out and buy a
one terabyte drive stick it in it's
about this big it works totally fine
right so we know that it's big I'm not
saying anything new but what does this
really mean for us right and it really
means that quadratic algorithms just
don't work so we're gonna do a quick I
hope people can see this we need you
quick kind of back in the envelope order
of magnitude calculation so I'm gonna
give you a one terabyte so about 10 to
the 12 size input and I'm giving give
you a 10 gigahertz ALU so this is faster
than what actually you have but it's
gonna be a single core single single Lu
right 10 gigahertz really fast so linear
time algorithm order n one terabyte how
long is this going to take
well we can divide it's a 100 seconds so
it's gonna be about a minute or two
right now n log n still really fast kind
of our benchmark for Billy fast
algorithms this is now gonna be an hour
or two this is a little bit troubling
already right and now we could go to
Andrew 10 which is really not that big
at all right if you open up your
favorite algorithm sex book
you say oh I have an N to the
three-halves algorithm you're really
happy how long is n root n on here well
it's about a year or two right you're
not gonna be waiting a year for your
computation to finish mostly because a
there's gonna be an error and so your
computations gonna be wrong and then you
have to restart it and there goes one
percent of your life or it's just going
to be crash huh it's gonna crash halfway
through your machine will die they'll be
an earthquake the power will flip and
you're gonna lose all of your
computation right so this is not tenable
so this is part of the reason that would
go to parallelism and part of the reason
for this workshop and part of the reason
for the diversity of the workshop wait
we have to solve this and verdun is
actually really small terabyte inputs
are not even considered big data by my
definition anymore and we don't even
have 10 gigahertz LEDs right so you have
to paralyze you have to go there but
there's another part of what makes sort
of it big data quote-unquote and I want
to say what is the shape of big data and
what does it look like and I'm gonna
give you a series of plots and we're
gonna vote whether or not it's big data
or not
don't ask me what these plots are of it
doesn't really matter right so here's a
plot I'm gonna tell you that it's log
log scale and somebody fit a straight
line through it right this feels and
looks like big data if you've seen big
data plots if you've seen big data
papers they're gonna have a plot that
looks something like this right to
compare here's a different plot this
doesn't really feel like big data even
if there were a whole lot of points on
it
I would conjure that it's still not a
sort of a big data plot again log log
scale sort of straight line ish usually
with a little bit of a kink big data not
really right
so there is a separation here these
things look very different from these
things but what does it really mean well
it means that our data is skewed so we
have whatever data said you're dealing
with if it is measured in terabytes
petabytes etc it's usually going to be
very highly skewed right it's going to
follow some sort of power law
as if distribution and so it's going to
have very long and very fat tails so
long tail by itself not really that
interesting fat tail by itself also
maybe not very interesting but the fact
that they're both long and fat is
something that's going to give us a lot
of trouble and headaches as would you
algorithm design weight and what does
this really mean is that your median and
your mean are very very different and so
you can't mean it's almost meaningless
in this context right there's a whole
slew of different examples you know the
mean salary of somebody in Seattle a few
years ago was not a meaningful statistic
whereas the median is so much more
meaningful I heard on NPR the other day
the BART strikers arguing because they
say well our mean salary is really
really high and they're saying well
that's the mean that's upper management
we don't talk about that more engineers
actually not that much right so it comes
in over and over again but median is
different from the mean and you're
different you're law of large numbers
here is slightly different it really
says that you will have one set of small
data points one sample that's going to
define your whole distribution it's
going to be way off the chart and
there's going to be a constant fraction
of the meet of the mean right so then
what do we do with this this is to me
this is big data it's big duh obviously
this is not that interesting but it's
skewed and the skew will come to haunt
us okay so for the remainder of the talk
let me talk a little bit about
parallelism right and I'll start with
kind of a little bit of systems and then
jump into models and kind of theoretical
models of how do we think about them and
then give you three kind of vignette
scenarios I'm thinking about MapReduce
algorithms and what works what doesn't
how do we what are kinds of rules of
thumbs that we rules of thumb that we've
developed over the years to kind of
combat these big data problems
okay so parallel systems there is lots
of parallel systems out there you go and
they have some of them have funny names
some of them have usual names you can go
on and you can be completely lost
in the sort of sea of different names
there's kind of MapReduce and Hadoop by
the famous ones there's extreme there's
Cassandra spanner pig link dried storm
etc there of course craft processing
units which were seen for quite I've
been around for quite some time and we
know how to program on them right
but what divides what how do we
categorize all of these different
systems so I'm gonna claim there are
three really divisions and three axes in
which we can look at
there's synchronous versus asynchronous
I think I just saw Joe come in so he's
gonna talk about asynchronous kind of
graph systems later this afternoon one
is is this a really computational system
that's underneath or is this more of a
database that supports querying and
doing complex predicates over large data
sets right these shores related but are
slightly different so I'm going to
separate those two and finally is it a
batch processing or is this something
that should run in real time right so
three completely different axes I'm
gonna focus on the left-hand side right
not to say that the other sides and the
other seven permutations are not
interesting but I'm gonna look on the
left-hand side for now
right so what is it that all of these
systems are highlighted maybe six but
there's definitely many more have in
common is that underneath they're all
really adopting the BSP model introduced
by less valiant almost 25 years ago if
not more right so this is BSP has come
to fruition and this is the model that
everybody's using so what is BSP BSP
says the following we're gonna start out
with our data of course living in the
cloud because it doesn't fit on the to
disk so it has to live somewhere else
we're going to partition it and
distribute the data amongst a few
different machines how many we'll get to
in a second so we're getting distribute
among different processing cores we're
gonna do the computation completely
independently so there's no
communication among the across the
dashed line right between this machine
and this machine while the computation
is happening and then we're going to
synchronize and this is where the
synchronous part comes in and we're
going to go back to the cloud
right so again we start with some data
out there in the cloud we find a way to
distribute the distribution could be
random or it could be something specific
and something a little bit smarter we
compute completely independently and
then we'll go back to the cloud now
there's not much you can do in a single
round of this so you get a layer it and
you're gonna do this multiple times
right so a few notes here what is the
running time of your computation
whatever it is well obviously it depends
both on the number of steps kind of the
number of yellow clouds I have over
there and the maximum running time per
step not saying anything deep here right
and so these are the two main things
that we're going to keep in mind as we
say oh is this algorithm better than
this other one now of course a real data
center doesn't look like this a real
data center looks something like eerie
blue and perfect in every way like this
this is from a wired article probably
about six months back right so this is a
real life modern data center this is
what's powering all your searches Gmail
images and YouTube and so on and so
forth now this looks nice and beautiful
but it doesn't really work all that well
so here's some notes just due to Jeff
Dean of what happens in the data center
and this is the other part of big data
and what we have to deal with so things
go wrong all the time right I'll let you
read through kind of what happens here
but basically your machines may fail
sometimes you have scheduled maintenance
you have to do updates you might have to
rewire your network somebody might trip
over the power cable these things happen
there's always fun things with
long-distance links and if you have your
favorite kind of engineer working in the
data center ask them they have lots of
many stories right but the point is that
things will fail all the time the
easiest thing that fails is your hard
drive fails right so you imagine your
data center is tens of thousands of
machines each one has a few hard drives
your mean time to failure of a hard
drive is maybe a year or two so if you
do the math you are having hard drive
fails all the time
and what does this mean it means as
you're doing your computation if you're
not aware and if you did not plan for
the fact that one of your machines will
fail your computation will actually
never succeed because one of them will
fail you'll restart thinking it's an
outlier then a different one will fail
then you'll curse that day you'll
restart again a third one fails the
fourth one fails and so on and so forth
right so you can make the hardware more
reliable or you can say why is it that
BSP has been adopted so widely is
because it's very Singh simple to make a
BSP computation Brazilian to failure
there are a lot of points and a lot of
check points where you can say I'm gonna
save my work or I'm gonna restart a
particular node because there is
separation as I work on a particular
machine that has some data assigned to
it it's not communicating with anybody
else it's not looking at any other data
and so if it dies for whatever reason I
know what should we start I know that I
need to get this data that was assigned
to it and I know I need to process it
again and I need to go forward and
that's it so I can actually it is very
resilient and this is what we see in
practice things get startup things die
and get restarted all the time it also
is surprisingly a good thing for
performance in the following way if I
know that one of my machines for some
reason is running slow I can just start
a second copy and have them Britten's
teach other right and see what finishes
first and in the beginning of the
computation where I have a lot of tasks
left this doesn't really matter and it
doesn't make sense but what I'm waiting
towards the end and I have just a couple
of tasks left over and I'm really
waiting and I'm like why is this taking
such a long time I can start a second
one so if it's the machine that's flaky
or the network that's busy or
something's wrong for whatever reason I
get a second copy and there's formal
analysis that you can do that says sort
of like you know power of two choices
but not quite you get a measurable
speed-up and improvement right so this
is why BSP works this is why all of
these systems if they're synchronous
underneath they're really DSP their
block synchronous parallel
right so what are the parameters of BSP
now if we want to go and we'll want to
think and analyze the particular
algorithms that we have and say is
algorithm a better than algorithm B or
what are the different trade-offs that
we're making what are the parameters
that we need to think about well I'm
gonna say by proof by picture there's
only a couple so one is the maximum
memory so what is the maximum input size
that I can send to any one box right if
I send too much that's one parameter if
I'm allowed to only say sort of send the
constant number of bits that's a
different system and the second one is
the parallelization so how many of these
machines do I have right do I have a lot
of them is this more like a p.m. where i
can have polynomial e many i would love
to have that or is it very few or is it
just a single machine and so it's
something sort of akin to the laptop or
a single a laptop from ten years ago
where i had a single core alright so
these are the two main parameters and as
you shift what these parameters mean you
get different systems that are out there
in practice right so again if we look at
we're going to look at this continuum
between the RAM and the PI Ram right so
a Ram is a degenerate BSP where I said
everything is there's only a single
machine right so if there's a single
machine the mapping phase is easy
everything goes to that single machine
there's no need to do any
synchronization across rounds because
everything is on a single machine right
so it's one round etc the PRM is
degenerate in the other parameter it
says I only have a constant memory or
really a couple of bytes bits per input
per machine and I'm synchronizing all
the time so I have very little input I
can't really do too much per round but I
can do many rounds and I can synchronize
across this mesh and now things come in
between on this continuum so am a
producer Hadoop the standard is sort of
you should think hundreds of thousands
of machines they're real commodity
hardware so they're sort of think of
them as you have a hundred laptops at
your disposal right that are all wired
together so they can talk to each other
and you don't have to worry about it
so you aim for a few rounds you can't do
too much work because communication is
there and it's expensive right but it's
sort of hundreds thousands if we go to
Prague alors giraffe which is the open
version of it or gpus it's slightly more
kind of finer grained it's closer to a
p.m. where I can do less I'm intended to
do less amount of work per round but
because of that the communication I can
do many more rounds and I structure the
communication in such a way to make this
happen so this is kind of the continuum
of the bsp space and so what I want to
say is how do we model this now how do
we talk about this and make it even more
formal so we're gonna make two
assumptions and so if you disagree with
these assumptions then you should go
have some more coffee and tea because
this is I'm going to assume this as
given right two assumptions one is that
again this is big data so your data does
not fit onto a single machine we're not
dealing with a degenerate case of a ram
is you have this data it's multiple
terabytes I have a terabyte drive here
it doesn't fit it doesn't matter it
doesn't fit that's it right the second
one is that the number of machines that
you have at your disposal does not grow
linear with the size of your data right
it would be nice if it did we might run
into communication other issues it'd be
a little costly but basically you don't
have that many resources you're a number
of your resources is allowed to grow
with your data but not in a linear way
it's gonna be sublinear right so again
specifically I'm gonna denote by mu the
memory per machine right and I'm gonna
make it be polynomial in sublinear so
answer them 1 minus epsilon for some
epsilon it's nice to think of these
epsilon says 1/2 roughly so you have
about square root n memory right not too
small but not that large either your
number of machines well they have to
there's a bound here that's trivial they
have to fit all of your data so it has
to be at least n over mu but I'm gonna
allow you to cheat and have more of them
if you really want to again it's going
to be sub linear
think of it as square root n so I have
square root n machines each with square
root n memory if you want n to the 2/3
I'll give that to you too if you want
more than n then we're in trouble and
I'm gonna write be very happy if I can
do this in the concept number of phases
constant number of rounds now something
like log n I'll be content I won't be
happy I won't be sad something like log
squared I'll be a little on the sad side
and if it's poly low if it's polynomial
if it's something like square root n
then I'm not really happy at all right
so I'm happy at order 1 I'm I'm ecstatic
at order 1 let's say I'm happy at log
log n I'm ok with log N and I get sort
of progressively sadder as this number
increases alright so this is the model
now you should come out with pitchforks
and a Sergey you haven't said anything
about communication we know from
streaming we know from other things that
communication is crucial and you've
mentioned communication and passing and
saying some things that are hard but in
your model you've said nothing about
communication whatsoever right so why is
this model not bogus and I can have a
multitude of reasons as to why I'm not
modeling communication right one of them
is that I just can't do it very
effectively there are a lot of things
that are happening in practice that are
very different from what we can model in
theory and so the two will actually not
align right another one is the fact that
these there are these failing resources
all the time and so I have to recompute
things and I have to recompute eight
things and this is ok this is not bad
where this is most striking is that
linear communication something that we
say is absolutely awful in the streaming
sense is actually totally fine and I'll
give you an example of this in a second
so the fact that I'm allowed linear
communication and I have to be allowed
linear communication to do a lot of
these problems makes communication a
much harder thing to think about right
and then the end it really comes down to
the following I'm gonna say I'm gonna
limit how much communication you can do
because of the two assumptions that I
start
you cannot have quadratic communication
because there's only sub and machines
each with sub and memory there's not n
squared bits to pass around they won't
fit someone anywhere right so I'm gonna
say you have less than N squared
communicate but less than N squared
total memory across your whole cluster
so your communication is limited if we
have a good reason than to go and
optimize for it then we can talk about
it but until then we're just gonna say
there's an upper bound on the
communication okay so with that in mind
we can start thinking about different
algorithms and different approaches so
before we go and really dive into
MapReduce we should talk about prm's
right so we've have this very rich very
well developed very nice theory about
PRM algorithms but how do they fit in
here do we have to just throw everything
out and start anew and the answer of
course is no so what they're our
simulation results they can say take
your favorite pea ramallah rhythm if it
doesn't take and it doesn't use too many
resources I can translate it directly to
a MapReduce cell algorithm right now the
upside is is that now I know how to do a
whole lot of things in MapReduce the
downside is is that since it's a theorem
it's gonna require login rounds and log
n again makes me content but it doesn't
really make me happy and it might
require log squared n and so on and so
forth and what's going on here is that
the PM is not using the full power right
part of my power as I said is I divided
this input and I have square root n
sized memory on this machine and the PRM
is saying well that's the same thing as
having like square root and individual
ones but I do have this chunk of memory
together I can do something that uses
all of this memory all together to do
something useful and I'm not so a
pyramid of a bar to say we know how to
do this can you do better can you run
this in the constant number of steps can
you use can you be better in work
efficiency can you use the resources
that you have more effectively so now on
to the three
things so the first one is going to be
reordering so this is kind of a trivial
example and a trivial statement to make
but it turns out to be extremely useful
which is that I can take my data set and
if it's partitioned randomly across
whatever machines or space that I have
it's not very useful to me it's very
hard to do basic computation whereas if
I reorder things if I just do a group by
for all the database people in the
audience then this makes it much much
simpler to answer much more complicated
questions and this is where the linear
communication comes in so if I want to
if I have a matrix that's given to me as
a set of rows so I know it's row I and
row I 1 as this particular element I 2
is something else I 3 something else and
so on so I have a matrix given me as
froze and I want to look at it as a
matrix of columns right so I'm just
doing a transpose this is something
that's going to take linear
communication you can prove this
formally or this is something that's
more or less intuitive right you are
kind of looking at every particular
element and it might be sent to a
different machine so it's going to take
you a long time to do this is really
fast right in practice doing a transpose
on the matrix you're not doing that much
work you're really partitioning and
putting it back together in a different
way this is something that's very very
fast and very efficient right and yet it
requires linear communication now if you
want to know why it's super fast we can
chat afterwards there are a lot of
system tricks that are underneath that's
making this kind of very feasible and
easy to do right sorting I have a multi
term multi petabyte input I want to sort
it this is doable this is not that bad
right sorting is actually not that hard
right so overall kind of what is the
goal here is going to say how can I take
this unordered large data set that I
have
and reorder it in the way that makes it
useful to me and it'll give you two more
concrete examples the first one is
against you gets a little bit of
intuition so I give you a set of edges
here there's eight of them and I say
what is the degree of X and I'm gonna
ask people
way in the back to say what is the
degree of accident you can't tell you
can't really see which one is X and if
you can't see there's one edge here one
edge here one edge here that's flipped
backwards there's one there so it's four
but if I were to double every edge in
lexicographic to sort them and say what
is the degree of X you can say that if I
scan through the input or if I partition
even by the first vertex it's a simple
counting exercise there's not much to do
here right so the whole point is if I
reorder the data and something
reasonable and this is a trivial point
here right this makes the problem much
much easier so let's do something
slightly a bit less trivial and let's do
graph connectivity so I don't say well
what is so I'm gonna give you a graph
and I'm gonna ask you how many connected
components does it have right really
simple question much harder question
when your data is in the cloud and it's
stored all over the place what is the
representation of a craft that makes you
sort of quickly see the number of
connected components well I'm gonna
claim that if I give you every component
as a star it's going to be much easier
for you to see then if I give you every
component as just all the edges in some
random arbitrary order so the goal here
is now going to be I give you a graph
and it's in some random order how do i
reshape it so that every component ends
up a star so I'm gonna have two
operations so the high level approach is
as usual kind of in these things every
node is initialized with some random ID
we're going to assume it's unique and
now I'm gonna change the layout and
change the structure of the graph so
that in the end it's a star and I have
two particular operations that I will
use to do this the first one is we're
gonna call small star so I have a node
it has an ID it's connected to four
other nodes I'm gonna say hey what is
the smallest node that's next to you
here it's someone let's connect
everybody who is smaller than you not
everyone but only people who are smaller
than you to the one right so the nine
here gets left alone but everybody else
is connected to the one and I have a
large star operation that takes care of
the
nine that says again look at the people
who are strictly bigger than you and
connect them to the minimum note so two
very simple very local operations that
you can trust me that you can do in
parallel for all of these right because
I'm what I'm doing is I'm just adding
edges I'm saying I'm gonna forget all of
the edges that exist in one step and I'm
gonna add new edges under these two
rules and I'm gonna do either small or
large all right so I serve with a graph
I sort of changed the edges I changed
the edges and I get a star in the end
great what can we say we can say three
things here so both the two operations
done individually but on every single
note at the same time will preserve
connectivity so if I do small star and
every single node or if I do large star
in every single node I actually preserve
the connectivity structure of the graph
so this is crucial because that means I
get the right answer the number of edges
that I have is going to be non
increasing and it's going to decrease
very quickly in the beginning and then
screen to plateau at something that
looks like a tree right with every
iteration and this the number of edges
here is really my communication cost so
even though I explicitly don't care for
communication implicitly I do care here
and I know that the communication will
reduce as I go in forward right and I
know that in the end these things
converge of every component is a star
with a smallest node in the center this
is the fixed point for the small star
and the large star operations and I can
then prove that combining these two in a
particular manner gives any convergence
in log squared n steps right now you can
say log squared n we know how to do this
from PRM style algorithms and I say yes
exactly but this is a much more local
and much more PRM Center
much more MapReduce centric view for us
right and they hear more to the point it
gives me sort of our less trivial
example of saying how do I transform and
change to the way the data looks to
answer a particular question for you so
this is all I'm going to talk about on
for now so the second idea and the
second view on this is a question of
corsets and so what our corsets corsets
generally if I give you a problem to
solve and particularly if it's a very
large problem you're gonna say you're
gonna think about it for a while and you
can say this every single bit of this
problem actually determined the final
solution or can I be a little bit naive
and say most of these things don't
matter most of these things don't matter
and there's sort of a core problem
that's embedded underneath and if I can
only solve the core problem I would
optimally or approximately optimally
solve their underlying problem so the
idea is going to be these corsets exist
we're going to look for corsets in
parallel then once we find a corset if
it's small enough we're gonna say we can
fit it onto a single machine and solve
it there because this is something that
we know how to do well so the overall
idea the high-level point is if I can
reduce the input size from n to about
square root n I go from a problem that's
measured in tens or hundreds of
terabytes to something that's ten Mick's
10 Meg's I can solve on my phone right
your favorite sort of applications are
solving 10 Meg problems all the time
right your picture sizes are way bigger
than that whenever you're doing anything
right so the challenge here is now to go
from the something that's large
distributed gigantic it's just something
that's small and reasonable right of
course it's now have come I think
initially from computational geometry
because it's easiest to see why this
should be true right Why should there be
a core of the problem that exists that
if only I could solve it on the core I
can solve it on a more general thing all
right so let's say clustering how many
clusters are here this is not a trick
question therefore right so there's all
the different colors these two colors
look the same but that's fine right
there's still four different clusters so
if I now take their clusters and I
remove a whole bunch of the points and I
ask you again how many clusters are here
you're still going to say
or right and still the same more or less
four clusters right now of course you're
gonna say well Sergei you can't just
randomly sample a small number of points
what if you miss this cluster completely
it's already small and I say absolutely
I never said that finding core sets is a
trivial thing to do all I wanted to
demonstrate to you is that they exist
and now we can talk about how do I
actually find a core set that's
reasonable and this is where all the
work is but then once I find something
that's much smaller than the original
input on here I can run my favorite
clustering algorithm find the right
clustering and then bring it up to the
larger data set and it's going to be
approximately optimal because if we can
prove a theorem that's as it is right so
let's talk more about clustering so I
did a lot of work on k-means about five
years ago
so I know k-means so i'm gonna do
k-means corsets right and how do you
find a k-means corset you do the
following you pick the first point in
your data set completely at random and
then the next point you're going to
select with the distance proportional
just sort of the cost of the clustering
so you're going to select them
proportional to the square of the
distance of in your center we're going
to do this in pictures if it's Monday
morning right so we take the first point
completely at random and now we're going
to recolor all of the points so that
darker points have lower cost right so
things here already pretty well covered
by the point that I took things here are
much less kind of well covered things
here is somewhere in the middle so I'm
going to now take and sample the second
point with probability proportional to
kind of how light it is so I select a
point it might be out here and I've read
you the coloring again and I keep on
doing this and what do I have in the end
so what I know in the end is that if I
did this just for K rounds I have a law
K approximation to the overall global
k-means objective the k-means objectives
ask you to minimize the squared distance
between the point of its nearest center
if I do this for K plus root K rounds so
if I keep on doing this a little bit
longer I have a constant approximation
I've chosen too many centers but among
these centers
there's K that form a constant
approximation so if I can only cluster
these K plus root K using your favorite
clustering algorithm for k-means then
you know that you have a constant
approximate solution on the big global
data set right so this is constructing
the core set the problem here what the
algorithm I described and you can say
it's either problem or not is that it
takes K rounds because every single time
I chose a new point I've recomputed the
probability distribution I chose on your
point again and so on and so forth now
if K is constant we're done because I
said constant makes me happy if K super
log n then I'm not super happy at all so
what happens if K is large our idea here
is going to be very simple
so the sequential algorithm said select
the next point proportional to this
distance metric well what if you don't
select a single point you're gonna
select a whole bunch of them right the
trick is not coming up with the idea the
trick is proving that this works but
I'll spare you the proof all right so
this is the sequential algorithm the
parallelogram says select a few points
with this distribution and this actually
works right so we can show that after
some log n divided by log L where L is
going to be my over sampling parameter
number of rounds I'm gonna sample some
number more than order K points in the
end that form an order one core set
right so what does this mean overall it
means that I'm going to do some amount
of work in the number of rounds that's
independent of K independent of the
number of points that I want to get in
the end I wanted to get K the initial
algorithm said do k k rounds now this is
something that's independent of K I'm
going to have too many points so I'm
going to over sample a little bit but I
can then re cluster them and I know that
they form a constant core set so if I
can only solve the problem on order K Oh
points I'm done and if K and if L I said
to be about square root n because that's
my sort of mental memory parameter I
have a constant number of rounds I have
order square root n points
and have reduced the input size from
terabytes to megabytes I solve it on
there and I know that this is a good
solution for the end right so you can
say okay fine clustering geometric
problems what about other things and can
you find a corset for other problems
that we're trying to solve and the
answer is we're going to look at the
following technique to find a corset for
things like matchings for things like
set cover and other problems idea is
very simple we're going to take this
huge input whatever it is we're in a
sample a part of the input we're going
to compute our solution just on the
sample and then use the sample to sort
of prune out things that are already
covered in some sense of the word
covered now this works exceptionally
well with greedy algorithms and we can
make this formal because really what
we're saying is that we're going to take
the seed solution as the greedy we're
going to reorder things and say these
are the things that are going to come in
first and then once we've solved that on
this particular input the rest of the
input doesn't really matter and we can
drop it so let me give you an example
with maximal matchings this is easier to
be seen so what am I trying to do you
give me a graph I have to give you a
subset of edges that form a maximal
matching right so to approximation to
maximum we're sticking to maximum
what are we going to do we're going to
give this very large data graph we're
going to take a random sample of the
edges now this random sample is small
enough that we can find a maximal
matching on the sample efficiently this
is where we're using the sequential
power of the model given that I've
selected these two bolder edges I'm
going to look at the original graph and
say which edges can no longer be a part
of a maximal matching given that I have
these two as selected as a solution and
I can drop most of them and now I have
something that's leftover and I'm going
to recurse and do the same algorithm on
the remaining edges so why does this
work so we can prove a key lemma here
that says the following the number of
edges that's going to be left over after
single-round is going to decrease by
polynomial amount there's some
trickiness here so I'm what I need to do
is I'm gonna sample with some
probability that it's super linear and n
divided by M so this is n to the 1 plus
C so this works for dense graphs this
approach would not work it for sparse
graphs because I would just end up with
all the edges but if I sample with some
probability and to the 1 plus C divided
by M that I know the number of edges
that's left over goes down by this
factor n to the C right and what does
this mean for me in the end this means
that after a constant number of steps
the number of edges that's left over by
after 1 over C steps is going to be
order n and so I'll be done right this
is the full proof in the interest of
time I'm gonna skip it so we can go on
to more fun things right so the
corollaries are that we can do this in
constant number of rounds given enough
memory if our memory is only slightly
superlinear so we have n log n memory we
get slightly below the login number of
rounds and of course what I'm competing
with is PRM simulations that say you
need log n steps and here I'm saying
here's how to get below log n and what
is the tool that I have is that I can do
a lot of things at the same time right
so I said if I sample this smaller input
now I can find a maximum matching just
on that sample in a single round this is
not something that you can do but the
PRM but this is something that you can
do here and we can do this through more
greedy algorithms you know
you can hope to I just don't know how
right yeah I don't know how yeah we'll
get to lower bounds in a little bit
right and so we can apply the same idea
to many other greedy algorithms right so
if we're doing basically a sub-module
function optimization subject to some
set of constraints for your favorite set
is that matrix is it knapsack is a P
systems is it something else the same
general approach will work right and we
can say what we're going to do is we're
going to take the full input we're going
to sample a set of constraints we're
going to find a solution that satisfies
those constraints only now on that
solution other constraints already
satisfied and we can recursively move on
and so variance of this hold there are a
lot of little details to work out to
make this hold precisely but this is
fine so the last talk I want to talk
last part of this I want to talk about
is working with graphs and so what are
the things to keep in mind and here
we're gonna get back to this well big
data is skewed data it's not just big
it's actually going to be skewed and
what does this mean when I'm walking
working with graphs it really means that
there will be small or nodes and
whatever graph you have that essentially
have linear degree right so for example
you can take the web graph and points
pointing to each other as web pages and
say well how big could a degree of a
node be who's crazy enough who's gonna
point to you know whatever it is right
so there's a fun anecdote this is not
true anymore
but a few years ago the number one
linked page said download Adobe Acrobat
PDF reader here right and everybody
linked to it because anytime you or a
government agency or somebody else had a
PDF you had a handy little link saying
well if your computer can't read PDFs
natively because five years they
couldn't this is where you can go and
download a PDF reader right the in
degree of that site was obscene and you
can't just ignore it when you're doing
your computation you can say oh it's a
one-off
right I'm just gonna ignore Adobe that
doesn't really work right if you're
looking at your follower graphs Twitter
is a great example of this right so
whoever here is in the room I'm guessing
you don't have more than a few thousand
or tens of thousands of followers
because Justin Bieber is not in the room
right Justin has over 30 million
followers so if you try to do something
with Justin you can't again if your
something and we're gonna look at
algorithms that are quadratic in the
degree they seem totally fine because
the average degree is small but the
average degree doesn't tell you anything
about the worst-case degree in the
worst-case degree is huge
and so it doesn't really work
recommendation graphs have the same
structure so the recommendation graphs
is simple you have items on one side you
have users on the other side and this is
people have rated recommended did
something with a particular item and you
can say well maybe I can imagine high
degrees on the item side because maybe
there is very popular products and they
get reviewed all the time but why would
you ever think that there's a person
who's reviewed hundreds of thousands of
items and you may think that and you
would be wrong there are people who have
reviewed hundreds of thousands of items
I don't know who they are but I know
that they exist in the data and you
can't ignore them and they will crash
your system if you don't think about
them ahead of time right so the whole
main point here is that you have to
change your algorithms and sometimes
it's easy sometimes it's harder so that
whatever your skew is in the data
doesn't translate into skew and
computation so concretely let's take
this question of counting triangles very
simple question I give you a graph and I
say how many triangles are there in this
graph and you say Oh Sergei there's a
really easy algorithm I know exactly how
to do this here's a three line well four
line algorithm that says the following
I'm gonna iterate over all of the nodes
for every node I'm gonna look at all of
its pairs and if there's an edge between
that pair I'm gonna increment the
triangle count now I'm triple counting
every triangle but you can divide by
three in the end it doesn't really
matter right so I look at the node V I'm
gonna look at all of its pairs I'm gonna
increment
triangle here I'm gonna look at a
different pair they're not connected
I'm not going to increment the triangle
etc right this is what you would expect
your undergraduate algorithms or not
algorithms course to come up with it's
totally fine on small data right running
Times Square over the degree seems
totally fine D regular expanders works
beautifully by regular graphs sparse
graphs even large sparse graphs will
fail you will be waiting for a long time
for it to finish because it's the square
of the degree now naively you can say oh
I'm going to paralyze this and what's
the easiest way to paralyze this well
the top line instead of for each you're
gonna do a parallel for each and say
well I'm gonna there's a lot of nodes
I'm gonna assign each node to just count
the number of triangles incident on it
right and there's some sort of snide
faces in the audience saying how could
you be so stupid as to do this but
people do this all the time right this
is the easiest way to paralyze this so
of course you're gonna do it this way
your running times changed from the sum
to the max has that changed anything in
reality no not at all right but people
do this parallelization and we ran this
just for fun and it has this very
annoying effect is that if you paralyze
it this way most vertices will finish
very quickly because most people have a
few friends or followers right and then
there'll be Justin and on Justin you'll
be talking for a long long time and
you'll be waiting now what this
translates to in reality is that you're
going to sit there and you're gonna say
hey after ten minutes these are very old
running times after ten minutes
ninety five percent of my input is done
right so just a couple more minutes and
then this will be done I can send the
email I can go to bed I can do whatever
right then you wait another 30 minutes
and again from 95 to 97 and a half and
you're like oh this is just totally
right there I'm almost done I can almost
go to bed like just another half an hour
I will totally hit this paper deadline
it's great right and then you wait
another 45 minutes and you've done no
progress and now you started thinking is
my
machine something wrong with it is my
cluster not working should I call my
sister I'm in the paper deadline time is
really approaching like what am I going
to do I'm hacking things up so I can go
directly from like the output to the
late a can compile and do all of this
right and then it's gonna run and then
finally this thing finished in an hour
but people see this all the time and
they call this sort of the curse of
glass reducer in that your input your if
your data is skewed and you're being
naive about it in ten minutes it's going
to look like you're almost done and in
an hour it's going to look like you're
almost done and in three hours it's also
going to look like you're almost done
and if you're a very patient maybe in a
day it's also going to look like you're
almost done but you're never actually
done because quadratic on 30 million is
a long time and this is going to take
forever right so what do you have to do
you just have to treat high degree notes
differently you know there's skew and
your data right so for example for the
connected components algorithm that I
showed you before it said I'm going to
look at my whole graph and I'm gonna
transform it into a union of stars right
and right there you should say hold on
Sergey stars are really bad from a skew
standpoint the middle node that has
degrees on order of millions tens of
millions hundreds of millions is not
going to be very fast and processing
updates from all of its neighbors right
so in reality what we look for is we're
not looking for these stars but we're
looking for short trees because if I go
degree from end to root on now I have a
two-level tree instead of a star it's
still something that I can deal with and
it's something that's much more
efficient here or you can be a little
bit clever about how you work with high
degree nodes right so how do you do this
for the triangle case it's actually
really simple so you say there are two
kinds of nodes there's most of us where
the low degree nodes and then there's
the celebrities there are the high
degree nodes so when we're counting
triangles for the low degree nodes I can
be quadratic in my degree it doesn't
matter
my degree is so small that quadratic my
degree is totally fine right so I'm
gonna say low is less than square root
of M high degree nodes I cannot afford
to be quadratic in my degree right
but if
I just restrict my degree to other nodes
who are also high degree then I know
just by definition that there's very few
of them there's not that many
celebrities so I asked celebrities to
count triangles among celebrities and I
asked normal people to count the
triangles amongst them
including celebrities right and what
happens so for the low nodes the naive
algorithm I'm square of the degree at
the most order and work per node for the
high notes there's I'm only looking for
other triangles composed of all board
all nodes a high degree there's at most
rude my degree nodes by definition to
Werdum so each is also going to produce
order m worth of work and so I now
balance these two and if I actually run
this my distribution becomes much more
normal instead of log normal and normal
distributions make me happy now it turns
out that threshold is actually
artificial here's the right algorithm
right the right algorithm says take the
lowest degree node look at its triangles
remove it from the graph those triangles
in our County look at the next lowest
degree node remove it from the graph can
be strangles and so on right so then if
you're looking at something these are
orange are my slides if you're looking
at something like this first you look at
all of these singleton nodes including
this one and now you have left with a
single triangle and so there's not that
much work to do right and so you can
actually simulate this instead of
actually removing a node you can say for
every node you can say oh who is going
to be ahead of you or below you in this
ordering and only do the right amount of
work so this was done by shank you know
seven I think he rediscovered it because
it's been done before and we've
rediscovered it again three years after
him so it's a very simple idea it's very
natural to do right and so now if you do
this in parallel and you do the same
thing in parallel you're actually going
to scale much nicer right you're now
going to have these heavy tail
distributions and so your algorithm
looks the same it's the same naive kind
of parallelization where your running
time is much better so overall you have
to do something to these troublemakers
so in the graph you are going to have
the troublemakers you have to treat them
differently you have to be spell
all about them in practice people often
hack something together because they
realize that this is going to cause them
trouble but often times we can be clever
in our analysis and say you know don't
do this sort of ugly horrible hack this
analysis tells us how to do it well and
so your everything is kind of load
balanced nicely across the way okay so I
think I have three minutes so I'm just
going to conclude so what did we start
with we started with big data and we
said big data is big and B is skewed
right and we said there's lots of
different systems for dealing with these
kinds of datasets right and they all
make different trade-offs they're saying
how much paralyzation can I achieve is
it going to be fine-grained is it going
to be coarse-grained is it going to be
towards the RAM side of BSP or towards
the PRM side of DSP but these are
systems issues underneath we're really
dealing with BSP over and over and over
again right and what this gives us from
a modeling standpoint is that we get to
interleave sequential in parallel now
what I've shown you some kind of
examples where this interleaving works
and I'm showing you other examples where
we could do a lot of work in parallel
and then would get it down to a smaller
sub problem and then solve it
sequentially right and so these were the
three kind of approaches that we said
right we can reorder things this is
something that's easy to do in parallel
this might require high communication
from analysis standpoint but it's
actually totally fine we can do this
course at trick of saying I'm going to
compute in parallel either trivially by
sampling or in some other way a core
size of the problem that's going to be
small enough for me to solve kind of
easily and use all the knowledge that we
have to solve it or and then finally
when working with graphs we said we have
to deal with these high degree nodes
they are going to come into trouble and
so if you're not paralyzing nicely
you're going to run into a lot of
trouble and I think that's it thank you